all right all right cool all right now
let's uh i'm going to buy
just [ __ ] from my
gun here
hold up c will give you access to the
calm wheel i'll meet you there when
you're done
we got discord
but apparently i can spray i'm trying to
figure out what it does ah tight can you
guys see that wait where are you
just small see my my sick oh hell yeah
back for blood that's what that is
exactly what mom is about
don't worry about it yeah
[ __ ]
that's a secret is that a microphone
blood don't no don't worry about it yet
sick oh look at mine
no i'm hey you just copied me dude
i don't like how everyone knows
but i don't oh mine is up on the d-pad
you just hit c
um are there weapons in here i would
like a shotgun oh no
uh you could maybe buy them even though
this is technically a sword off i think
but
oh yeah
in here yeah
orange the orange box oh there actually
is a shotgun here you mean i hate 12. oh
yeah i think i think i do have one
technically but yeah
yeah so every character you pick alana
will have the weapons that they always
spawn with but then you can obviously
find better ones throughout the game
i'll try it out and just start with
with this
headshot see that did you all see that
one i did i did it
i think you're making it up all right
now we're going to succeed everybody get
the boards now
now bot holly will actually secure it
who was that guy i was a zombie no but
there was a guy walking around who did
not behave like a zombie at all i think
oh there's a couple of npcs
there is a solution there is a zombie
currently here that was power walking
and it looked very strange
hmm
it's dark huh
there's a pistol there with pistol or
it's a sidearm
what do you think i'm some kind of [ __ ]
oh i'm sorry apologies
all mic rifles only oh no what was that
noise
oh i didn't buy my toolkit this time
whoops
whoopsies
oh yeah the ones in the walls would just
leap out at you
yeah they sure did i got you i gotcha
this this shotgun slow um because i
remember there being one at camp that
was it was like an automatic that that i
would like to have but
we gotta board up all the
oh there's a big lad here somewhere i
can hear him but i can't see him oh he's
on me he's on the man the lad is on me
where are you yeah where are you
okay is this like a fortnight situation
yeah yeah yeah
window
i see okay
where did that ladies respond from where
the [ __ ]
petrify these windows
oh wow these are right next to each
other that sucks so what are the ways
that this is different to uh left 4 dead
then it's got a card system mechanic
alana it does better graphics and that
is it
all right cool
they tried they're called cleaners in
this game instead of whatever they're
called there's
okay no i don't think so i have whatever
i have is a sauna oh god
christ oh there's an a12 over here
that's automatic okay that's an
automatic i'm trying my goddamn best to
[ __ ] figure out how to get over there
oh there's a ladder right here oh that's
where i'm picking i really appreciate
that thank you thank you a lot
you're inside of it that i saw something
in my peripheral but i wasn't sure if i
saw something like that oh someone said
they uh changed the font on the four
so said oh
yeah yeah yeah i'll take it
i'll take it okay tight
i'm a big fan of mom
i think she's got a good storyline you
got spunk
yeah
all right all right let's get that out
of here
so we just came in here to board up some
doors
now we're leaving yep
we have we're going to clean the library
big boy
double big boys over here got one
a couple of big lads
those big lads oh hey wow you okay he
has actually a lot more range than i
expected
oh yeah they will they will launch
do they have ammo crates lying around
there's rifle ammo here yeah you'll find
[ __ ] kind of all over the place stupid
idiot
oh if you think you're the only one with
a shoddy also you're gonna you'll be
totally fine
whatever i picked up was not shotgun
ammo did that mean i just picked up
somebody else's
dirt bag
yeah the shotgun for you
so can i drop whatever ammo i picked up
no i don't think so you could drop it if
you could drop money yeah maybe you can
you could drop bamboo
yeah i just picked up rifle emma no more
pistol ammo you just press tab and i'll
bring it up
oh no
there you go i dropped them just here
all right we got the uh oh oh
uh don't know what ping is all right
we're figuring everything out one step
at a time i left a bunch of ammo down
here i don't know how to ping are you
playing are you playing on controller
uh no mouse keyboard a q
q
here
all right since uh
let's try to do this uh yeah section
before the horde gets here
yeah this is where the game glitch and
we all died
yeah that was weird
yeah scripted it's weird in a game like
this yeah
absolutely you son of a i hate you it's
the same glitch can't believe it
i'm checking in here
oh no oh no oh no
we're good we're good
what is this
oh no dude in the window oh oh look i
[ __ ] that guy's still alive
i'm gonna heal the [ __ ] up right now oh
[ __ ] intense in here it is the music's
picking up it's giving me exactly a lot
of shotty ammo here alana a lot of shots
thank you i
appreciate that are you still alive and
where did you go
he jumped behind you
all right let's let's try to run
upstairs yeah if you guys want to go
upstairs i'll try and cover this back
door oh god says oh big boy oh god andy
for [ __ ] sake
i'll leave you alone for a second pour
it in
i hate these gentlemen there's another
guy
are you good up there
yeah we're all right you guys save all
the survivors
there's another [ __ ] big guy coming
jesus christ
i'm gonna ask him i'm gonna ask him a
question you know i opened up this room
uh the secret cool room okay i gotta
watch the door because they're pouring
in
i think we're good now there's some good
weapons there's some good weapons up
here y'all yeah are there are there
different tiers to your weapons like
it's yeah like green blue
normal like rpg stuff
well i don't seem to be able to pick
this up in my primary weapon slot oh no
so you're s
wait which
hmm so i can't i have two shotguns and i
can't swap out your shotgun is your
primary yeah
oh my god we're running out of time
gonna have problems with seven seconds
we're gonna have a lot of problems
no no it's fine it's a fun noise yeah
hey you know what i'll watch
where are the [ __ ] survivors
do you guys
survive
no i have not seen them
oh god
oh ray
no no you're good you're good okay
things are starting to become not good i
got an axe don't worry just uh you know
find the survivors
preferably fast i didn't see any
survivors what are you guys doing maybe
they're up here tim i don't know
don't worry i got it
oh i found them okay let's kill them oh
they're sort of hot the survivor is hot
she's sort of hot
one room there's an incredibly dangerous
tactic here yeah that's true and the
window is wide open
oh i didn't see the hole oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god
can you get them
i don't even know where guys i'm getting
so much money for us we're so rich nice
share it
uh yeah yeah we actually do [ __ ] i think
yeah when you pick it up it picks up
everybody
okay let me head up to you i just jumped
out of the [ __ ] third floor
all right
okay i'm gonna drop down as well i gotta
find where the stairs is so we just
needed to come find them and now we just
leave them
no you'll see them running out with guys
there's the spares asking got it friends
i'm still in the building like me and
being an idiot
well uh you're really far away you'll
yeah you'll figure it out you'll figure
it out oh they're with me okay so are
you a zombie or no you're i'm looking
for a little bit oh that's jump out it's
just telling us
should we just go do it yeah yeah come
for me come for me please
okay so yeah uh the stairs are on this
side of the building
oh wait hey let me go to you let me go
to you okay oh they're over here yeah
yeah
oh you went back downstairs okay i'm
looking upstairs like a [ __ ] oh no uh
on the top story i just like jumped out
oh you jumped out the window okay what
are you doing [ __ ] go i'm doing my best
not you
what this is a bad strategy i hope that
you the survivors just like just
straight up teleport i don't even think
they like walk
i saw one of them jump out of the window
they landed perfectly it's very
impressive ooh you've never landed a
jump before in your life
they did the olympics thing as well
where they like put their hands into the
air and then yeah
charges and i was like [ __ ]
are we beating that little fancy wrist
flick they do yeah
beat the horde what the hell this this
survivor just pushed me i know i'm
actually finding them like really
annoying oh he's also hot
i was going to say way scarier than the
zombies
the fact that they just
yeah
all bunched together in one room with no
weapons with open windows just like
what's happening to us
that was so easy now that we didn't have
a bot
yeah
moana carrying the team
big character doing my best
oh my gosh
i've got so much money look at all the
money we have now so what does supply
points do for you supply points uh when
you are
out of the game
like the yeah you could buy cards uh
from the little card ladies vendor yeah
yeah at the base gotcha okay okay okay
it's another in-game currency
yeah again hence my fear
they're thinking about it they're
thinking about it yeah they're thinking
about it they're like if this game if
this game doesn't become a success we're
i was telling you wait when we were
playing uh uh new world i was like you
know what i was playing with somebody
mike i was like you know what mike
it's it's it's obviously like everybody
in the industry is like no more
microchips actually we hated i was like
you know what mike i'm glad that you're
one for it
you're standing on the other side you're
like
oh i mean like michael
buy anything if it's available
accidentally
it's the best don't worry we'll get you
the time you need
the only microtransaction that i have
bought in the last i think seven years
was a five dollar dog in sea of thieves
oh was it a sheba
yeah
that's incredible
i don't i don't even do dlc none of it
none of it
i bought too many overwatch loot boxes
to uh
[ __ ] right now alana you're doing a
thing of like my my my kids will never
watch tv you're doing that thing all
right
you're trying to shame us
let me feel okay okay i for sure am
i'm doing my damn best out here
get rid of that tv oh my kids don't play
on they don't go on the internet i would
never let them yeah but it's
microtransactions i'm trying to be the
change that i want to see in the
industry you know what i'm saying
does uh does anyone else i like buying
dlc i mean what can i say
what can i say uh your shotgun ammo if
you still need it i'll take it because i
don't nope apparently i need it so
little that i can't even pick it up all
right you're you're filled thank you
though i'll pick it up there's a blue
suppressor here if anybody needs a blue
suppressor oh you can get weapon
upgrades yeah
that was my blue suppressor and i got
rid of it yeah there you go okay i took
it okay it's like an apex bubble okay
yeah there's a
yeah there's barrel there's clip there's
scope and there's stock and they have
different variants like rarities yeah
yeah you'll find like oh
sometimes just randomly you'll find like
a super gold
awesome
weapon can i like kill myself with a
backpack or
yeah yeah self-rest you get self-rest
too
you put you put down a laser shield when
you're rezzing people guys
remember to like and subscribe
oh
you know what i think of that
get [ __ ]
are we ready
but then somebody open the door let's
watch this yeah i'm good let's go oh i
opened the door i ruined it yeah you
ruined my sweet insulting tags
apparently the jukebox if you're gonna
upload this to youtube andy apparently
everyone's saying just like either mute
the game audio or there's something in
game because it's like one of the only
instances oh yeah
oh really yeah that was uh oh is that a
thing i should it didn't get hit on
twitch though on kind of funny switch it
didn't get pinged okay i know youtube's
real way more aggressive about that yeah
excuse me i'd like to book a room
yes ma'am can i help you a room please
absolutely not
that's fair i'm just going to mute the
game audio yeah give a super silencer on
options
oh do you have to
what is it music volume yeah
oh it's weird now though
yeah it's kind of weird yeah but it's
just here then i can turn it back on
wherever there's a jukebox but i think
we're coming up on a jukebox it's coming
up right it's coming right up yeah i
hope they they get a patch for that
it's very much like that a scene in uh
shaun of the dead
oh i know music starts playing zombies
in the bar everybody's having a grand
time like super unsettled by the silence
yeah it's really weird it's not good
life is strange all over again
i went to a cool rocker bar
to be fair this is more accurate to what
it'd be like in real life for sure
open the gym as someone who was once
once a teenage girl i never did that oh
you too yeah there's some good ones
those are wild
i can open this door oh open it up
a ranch rifle
there's a there's a lot of [ __ ] in here
if you want it's pretty sick i love [ __ ]
dude there's money in here a bunch of
help
you got money in here
oh i hear somebody angry oh what oh
motorcycle jacket that's cool find that
there's a jacket in here that i bought
there's a big oh my god
how did he get in there
oh
you can't blow the [ __ ] back
uh there's pills here people need it
more shoddy ammo lana there's also uh i
think i'm all close
i thought there was like
barbed wire laying around all over there
was and i think i accidentally picked
some up i did you could put something
down like you could put it down in front
of like a doorway or something yeah is
that because we're expecting a horde oh
yeah yeah i think yeah we have to start
the jukebox he's gonna bring in the
horde so you can put it by the jukebox
or by the way yeah we're essentially
turning on the jukebox to take attention
away from the survivors that are trying
to get away free i just put it in the
front door
yeah
which um you know maybe i shouldn't have
done but i did it so it sure did yeah
there's a bunch of molotovs behind the
bar as well
yes pick up a molotov
is there more barbed wire or is that it
i guess um that might be it might be it
oh great this is a good mp5
there's a blue one right here
my barrel is better my stock is oh i got
it i love that dude
how big it is it's how you use it
what's up hey
i was just saying i was just saying to
my chat i've never had a pop talk
oh you missed it hey tim neither of mine
oh you're both missing out
yeah but yeah hey hey you're better it's
all good
have you ever heard of hamburger helper
no what the hell is that oh my god okay
americans be silent please this is very
important yeah
what do you think hamburger helpers
what do you think it is
i think it's like
hamburger helper it's either a side that
you get with a hamburger to enhance it
mm-hmm or it's like a smaller hamburger
both of babies great guesses tam both
great guesses i only learned about
hamburger helper last week and i'm still
furious about it
it's like
a thing that goes with pasta you buy it
in a box in american supermarkets and
it's like a pasta flavoring
called
hamburger helper
well you see you put it on pasta yeah if
you google it all of all of the examples
of hamburger helper is that it's like
just [ __ ] pasta why is that what
happened i don't know tamp the mascot
looks like glover
yes this is
it's a little glove it's super weird i'm
so i'm very upset the blind america
explain
uh oh my chat's trying to tell me that
i'm wrong i'm not wrong look at the box
odd google hamburger helper it's
entirely possible you can use it for
pasta
just pasta
what is the what is the non-pasta use
for hamburger i have no idea because all
i can find is [ __ ] pictures of it
with macaroni
are we ready
yeah yeah i'm ready
third guess was going to be like just
hamburger meat that had been like
smooshed up
yeah
intellectual all good guesses for
american things hey what's this yellow
guy that's on my map
uh i don't know oh also chad
the audio completely so oh those are uh
oh those are the people here
oh can you i just full-on muted my audio
i'm muted oh you muted the whole game
yeah i just moved the whole game on my
mic it's like way louder than it should
be okay i don't think it's
music it's just like
oh is it uh i think somebody said it
might be sound effects or something yeah
oh [ __ ]
okay
so that didn't work i've muted it
let me also try it
oh i'm gonna die okay okay
someone said it sounds like evil eye by
through manchu and
what the hell is like the music volume
didn't turn it off that sucks no it's an
sfx which means that i'm not playing the
game without sound effects that is
lovely i'm lowering my game volume a lot
chad sorry dude i just full blown muted
it that's hilarious i have a super
silence around right now and all my
weapons
oh my god
that grenade is so close yeah i wish
more games would have like a streamer
mode or just something like that
i feel like i feel like hello
we're getting really good at it yeah oh
[ __ ] sorry i didn't realize right
everything hurts i'm done yeah without
the without the game audio it's time to
figure out whose way you know what i'm
saying i am down so if anyone i am also
down oh i'm coming
okay
i'm getting killed haven't you got
better things to do hey how about if i'm
the medic i res people real fast that'd
be a cool okay so apparently hamburger
helper actually comes with pasta
oh
like you buy the box and it's with the
pasta you're the only one alive right
yeah trying to revive i'm trying to be a
hero right i just got hit oh god that
was not good that was not great oh that
was a j.o champion
i shot him i saw him
and you're the medic right yeah
i'm like just chilling in some ass i'm
cool you guys are good oh there's stuff
behind us
i love it i got the x i've got the x
okay oh big guy get up
oh jeez just don't actually
don't ask me for anything and we'll be
fine oh this guy's
now nope we got to keep this no we got
to fix it i'm going to fix it
okay
the pill is really the pain oh i'd let
go of too early
i think there's uh what six buses or is
there how many survivors that we need to
save we only have one of six come on get
down with the sickness
well please dmca open up your head and
let it flow into me
this is good this is good this is this
is alleviated
yeah it's richard cheese
oh
oh that's fire oh my god
this is so weird it's so much harder
with no audio it actually no the music
cut off
well yeah but we have to fix it we're
gonna keep going
oh my god i've got the uh sfx down but
the master will you want now so i can
hear all the characters just going ugh i
know you can just get them panting a lot
oh if you're into the zombies
strike we don't know yet
you can just picture them standing in a
voiceover booth right now yeah
that has not been mixed
i think we're almost done i think we're
almost safe all right
uh what's push we gotta fix
don't want to catch an infection i'm
healing one more time and this thing's
about to hit me oh right next to you
right no i took it for you
i got it all right here we go
okay it's happening all right i think i
think oh behind me hello oh my god
the lodge boy is here oh yeah he's
outside with you oh no
oh god yes massive barrel
oh god
how do i hit v
okay thank you
hold on all right final bus
final bus we're almost done
we're almost done
with our
adventure yeah
not even close to being as nervous as i
was the first time without them
it's actually pretty chill oh it's like
minecraft on creative mode
me and my knife are just putting in work
over here just no one's getting in
through this week yeah you you would
londoner
[ __ ]
i think the first time i've eaten knife
on the streets
you get me you're done
oh no big man a large man
hang on let me come let me come back
around nope that failed oh no why
oh that's the big man you're talking i'm
in here if you value your undead life
i've got a knife and i know how to use
it
i'm going down
all right i'm on the pool table okay we
got him i'm getting you right yeah you
guys still there oh it's really quick oh
do you use the uh yeah if you have i
forgot what the item is but you can do
it later yeah yeah oh we have big issues
in here
big issues they call him
come on
oh god oh tim is healing
i think we actually the bit was over we
defended the jukebox and then we tried
to get out
i'm just going to take the dmca that's
fine
i can take the heat
i'll live life on the edge i'm not
playing this on youtube so i'm good i
was planning to but youtube doesn't get
as mad they just run ads i'm fine with
that
steal my money just don't steal my whole
channel you know
let me shut it all down stressful
dude we're just back like
okay here's the thing check this out
gamish oh i should find royalty free
music to play that's right it's a good
idea
i wonder if we could replace the jukebox
file
in game files i bet you you can
play something else yeah
i used to do that when i played
battlefield back in the day 1942
battlefield vietnam you could put your
own music in the cultists
dude yeah i remember like uploading
music onto my xbox and playing halo and
hell yeah dude just dude
we're doing modern warfare the first one
multiplayer with uh metal gear solid 3
soundtrack
so what what should i this is my first
time coming here after actually
completing any portion of the campaign
so what what's the best action to take
at this base camp so all of this alana
can just be done in your tab menu
if you hit the tab menu all like all of
those options are there they're just
people at desks but yeah do it yeah
representing like i'm the gun guy i'm
the whatever right so this really is
just sort of a a 3d version of a menu
yeah and then there's like a shooting
range out here that you could shoot all
the guns with go and try out all the
attachments
so i'm going to go campaign decks i'm
not
really sure how to start on this i feel
like the tutorial didn't help me yeah do
campaign decks and then uh
like go make a custom deck that's not
your starter deck
i need to go buy cards where do you buy
cards from um
yeah supply lines okay so we go
customize one and then i want to edit it
yeah and i think they they uh appear
basically like ranking so you want to
put the one you want most at number one
yeah
so each can have 15 cards
um
so you're essentially selecting cards
that you will find throughout the run
oh i see but i only have uh seven cards
right now yeah so you like you'll have
seven that pop up that's how it usually
is when you start off and then the more
you
find uh what you'll want to do a lot is
hit tab and then go to supply lines wow
okay
oh [ __ ]
yeah oh there's a lot to this and then
the uh oh i got i unlocked one oh okay
and then you can essentially buy cards
from these different supply lines with
that red inventory whatever it's called
i figured i got it okay um
and like tam said you set up your deck
and the deck the card on the top of the
deck is most likely to appear during a
run
so you can organize that order yeah you
kind of want to like prioritize which
ones you have like if you know that
you're going in there if you know you're
you have a card that has insanely good
healing perks then you want to put that
one on top because you feel more most
comfortable with it
got it okay so that's ammon capacity
healing efficiency well i kind of i'm
gonna want all of these because that's
all i have so far yeah i think it's like
and then i just need to absolutely
overwhelmingly complicate it but i think
it's cool
like once you're getting it now i was
confused at first but now i'm getting it
i'm getting it i see okay
like my
my card on top uh a melee kill
heals two health
and i want that one to show up you know
if i do what during your run i would
love for that one to show up and be an
option so i'll select that one i see so
i have that too that's battle lust yeah
yeah
how do they not let you rename the deck
you can custom you can
click on the
i don't know how i would describe what
that symbol is oh there is i got it okay
i'm going to call this
babies baby's first dick i don't care at
all about nearby copper so i'm going to
move my name mine's twitch prime i know
what i'm about
nice i love the copper though you have
so much more money going i made my first
tech coffee but i'll be the money guy
yeah i'm honored thank you ray there we
go
uh i'm here bragging right into the
bathroom chat wait second chance sounds
really good i have one extra life yeah
that's the one i put number one okay
we're gonna do that yep threw it out
second chance is number one and then
battle lust
okay this is pretty complicated but
we'll figure it out oh totally yeah i
think it's very i think it's like
i think it's like jrpg system level
complicated
yeah
it's it's definitely intimidating like i
when i first came in to try this game by
myself i was off put by it and i was
like i'll just wait until i play with
andy i was like i don't even want to try
this we'll learn it later yeah pretty
much
turtle rock just appeared one day i was
like so i played final fantasy this
weekend and then someone else played
cameron was like so i was playing
kills while at critical health recovery
i don't care that much about that heavy
attack
whoa that's cool
there's one that i really love it's
called combat knife and i think it's oh
you really like that i've got that i
think it's pretty a pretty common one
but if you
like i like selecting if you're if you
want combat knight to pop up select a
character who doesn't start off with a
melee as their secondary
i don't
mom does not
i will trade my combat knife for a
combat wife
oh wow that's what i'm saying wow
no i actually don't what does that mean
literally no i don't know what you're
saying no idea what it means
so like if you don't have a knife as
your secondary or like a machete or
whatever
so your melee is kind of just like you
push zombies away you don't really have
a melee i think mom starts with the
belgian
uh how else do i see what else she
starts with all i can see is that she
starts with the belgian she has one plus
support inventory
and oh that's how i had the instant
revive that's how i picked ray up so
fast
one instant revived by level which is
sick i think i'm going to play this mom
but i can't tell what uh
well either way like if you if you
prefer having a sidearm like i like
having a basic handgun as my sidearm
that means that you don't have a melee
weapon to
stab people or whatever but combat knife
gives you
instead of just pushing zombies away
with your fists or whatever you're
attacking them you essentially have like
a stab and it's like a one shot kill to
the head on the smaller zombies i see
yeah okay so let's pretty much combat
knife up a bit higher
so i put second chance first because
that sounds awesome
battle lust is merely
kills
heal to health and then calm vitamins is
plus 15 health which is also really good
okay i feel pretty good about that and
then i'll i'll just test it out
see what happens i love it
i love that phrase are we feeling gamers
how are we feeling really good i'm ready
to i'm ready i'm ready all right let me
get this out let me get this one out of
there and put this down um we need to uh
sing the pledge of allegiance first yes
or whatever oh yes please i pledge
allegiance to that of the united states
of america and to the republic that's
all i know they say that's the only bit
they say that's the only one i know
you don't know as much it goes further
than that
invisible do you really have to do that
every morning and justice for all yeah
that's
wild yeah do you have anything like that
in the uk uh no
no no no you guys are missing out it was
great
okay so here's one thing we can do right
now
all right yeah let's do it we can
start
past that mission
um
because i've i've passed that mission we
can pretend we beat it so you know when
we pretend we beat it yeah we definitely
beat it yeah exactly so let's go to the
next mission then
absolutely easy easy peasy here we go i
mean cool that means i can put my audio
back to normal then yes yeah that's
exactly good
yeah i'm just gonna take the l on any
dmca issues screw it
because i think that actually made that
a lot harder for us yes yeah absolutely
not being able to hear anything
absolutely
and also just being distracted by every
single one of these characters being
like oh you thought you could get me i
need to reload and be like hey you ever
shot a gun before because you're like
you end up shooting your teammates all
the time
hey same team
you're supposed to be the soldier
kind of petered out there
could be a soldier it's still affected
it's all you know it hit me i i dude
attacked by zombies
hey andy you're pretty hot no
everybody's hot literally every single
one of them is hot walker is hot
i'm convenient for the lowest part
dark is hot they're all hot you look
like um
the hot goth nurse in in
uh persona 5. tam said i look like the
young hot version of edna mode from the
incredibles yeah she does he didn't know
that
he did say absolutely right
100 percent great now i can get it
uh she shrunk and she got older
so it has corruption cards here i'm not
supposed to click on any of these i just
continue no yeah but then you'll start
off it'll give you four cards to start
off and then you can
select five
cards after that oh this is a good
deck
these are the ones that i put in the
deck so i should really pick all of
these right
uh well when you select one one will get
one will replace it
so one second chance
yeah immediately
and clicking them doesn't do anything so
i'm just going to go f to continue
wait really
yeah didn't it didn't change anything oh
now i have the the drawing cards okay
one extra life
love to see it
i feel like i'm always worried about
ammo i'll go with extra ammo
man we're totally gonna pop off here
this is good this is the one this is the
one yeah without a doubt this is the one
i'm feeling mediocre about it
we've lost contact with the supply team
working on repairs at the old diner
across town remember to buy you can buy
stuff also delivered that dude's talking
don't pay attention about it don't pay
attention
but he's only he's exclusively moving
his jaw which is very distracting
but the refrigeration he's high on drugs
is what he's guys this guy's playing the
uh don't let my arms touch the side of
my body game
my least favorite games yeah it sucks
um all right so here's what we should do
one of us get i'm going to get the tool
kit all right
and
cubby i'll buy like a defibrillator and
maybe you all buy something else or
whatever okay but you'll see what slots
they fill it's really confusing and i
don't think it's communicated very well
aren't you the dealership right
i just hit the team supports a lot
that's a good point right it's great i
got the tool kit
okay
i'll grab uh i'll grab an ammo pouch
there you go
i'm not at all convinced that i just did
the right thing but um
i'm sure we'll be fine we did great the
last mission all right we'll be able to
do short guard shifts in a week figuring
out one one you know what ray i'm going
to buy d5 how about that right i'll take
the toolkit when you'll pick that up
i've got a d5 i've got a couple no but
like i'm the healer so like maybe you
can just take my defib if you want it
i'm sorry do we need it do you want me
to take it pick up that toolkit yeah
yeah okay there you go there you go
you're good you're good
so the toolkit a lot of those like
secret rooms that you can enter if you
have one oh my god and the rooms will
have money and ammo and guns that dude's
still talking huh he's still going yeah
well where where did he go he's like
listen i have story to tell you i have a
lore please listen please listen to me
that like their bodies don't even exist
on my screen they're just i hear voices
in that room that won't stop that
exposition baby
my game are you still down you got to
get it out somewhere
don't know how to project my voice
watch me [ __ ]
thanks chat
tamora defended ray thanks man my hero
it said that to me earlier it was like
oh you defended andy and i was like you
don't have to broadcast that
i don't i'd rather people my little
secret my dirty
and then they go around telling everyone
how they give to charity it's like
are you doing it for for real i always
just think of the uh
the curb enthusiasm episode of the
anonymous donor
yeah i've just been watching through
that so um did you know that andrew
goldfaub is in uh an episode yeah
everything is the best
30 rock
no he's in he's in both he's in both
yeah that's amazing everything
absolutely that's absolutely amazing
what a good boy
he's great
um
where did we go oh oh through this house
that's right hold on i'm just grabbing
[ __ ]
have you played through this before andy
[ __ ] you graffiti
oh yeah we played through these missions
earlier today on streams
i didn't do that okay good news
i may have done that
i would have them probably a
where did he go
oh i got stuck oh no i got you guys i
got jeffy
okay okay you're fine you're fine i'm
just kidding i'm taking a risk super
safe i just need more brightness
you're good there's nobody by you you're
fine
all right kind of pop off
oh yeah those heels in here
is this unlimited we can only use one
right no we need one each
oh good cause there's a good gun right
here this m4
oh yeah real good gun ooh
someone watched everything yeah
whenever someone graffiti is on the wall
the graffiti is always so neat
yeah make a little bit yeah that was a
good amount of [ __ ] again it's it's
ubisoft ass graffiti
the zombies are here yeah
right here oh no
what you're going to pretend you didn't
ride it right just draw a giant dick on
there come on now
yeah
oh great utilization of that i'm taking
that stock i'm just grabbing copper
everywhere
yeah we're going to be so rich after
what do you all want to do after this
like where do you all want to go or when
we thank you
guys let's hit up vegas let's go to taco
bell order one of everything you've
never been to vegas no oh vegas is
pretty cool huh
i've been to vegas one time and it was
when you were there lana oh for dice
yeah
it's a good andy you
oh yeah so those dudes i don't know what
to do with them i don't know if we just
you're supposed to just avoid them can
you
i don't know honestly i don't think so
we were thinking like do we just avoid
them so they don't call the horde is
there a way to avoid them can we just
run away you know is it the is it the
snitch
yeah oh i've been grabbed by a large man
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] he's very big and i
am quite high
oh
i don't feel good about any of it
i'm going to heal i'm just stabbing
people
yeah you're good i'm just chilling in
the corner when i'm threatened i just
start stopping
again we know you're from london
i'm going to defibrillate you sorry
i got i got you
it's interesting uh how you get so much
blood all over you that it's kind of
hard to differentiate oh yeah
what's happening yeah yeah that happened
earlier kevin i was like kevin you're
shooting nick oh everybody's in blood i
don't know i can't see [ __ ]
yeah i i did increase the brightness
right i did try to
go behind you behind you
i [ __ ] hate the vomit guy yeah come
to the garage if you want to stab him
i like to think that he was intimidated
enough that he was like nah [ __ ] up
dude nothing's from the streets that
guy's going knife yeah i'm getting out
of here
damn just threatening like the look
that's a huge knife bro
the local youth
come out here if you want to stay here
well i hear
oh careful there's going to be a thing
that's like stuck
oh no
oh i see screamer guys again
hey [ __ ]
why did what what
who what
like one of those enemies that like
jumps from surface to surface oh god
oh you can get it and you can get it and
you can get it
what a stabbing
tim have you heard of audi
oh jesus christ no
audi
yeah oh god who's that
very small british rapper
no i don't think so
let's not wait around for them to come
back
i'm so freaking low health holy [ __ ]
yeah i'm a very big fan of this oh my
god i'm on 19. i got you i think i can
do a little hero
uh magnifying glass we got over there
we have to deliver things
i assume i have to take it to the
magnifying glass what is this amazon
they making us work uh through the
zombie apocalypse
the other thing is right there okay
bezos who wants to deliver
i marked the other one i actually love
playing two objectives frankly so if you
need help i will do it
oh yeah there's also money in this car
if you want to get money in that car uh
hold on i'm gonna drop it off
i'll go to the call make a little
deposit at the uh the safe room there
ozzy there we go oh something other side
this wall okay i got the money all right
come on the other box
we can we can just exit right now or we
can loot a bit more but it's probably
i feel like there's something on the
inside of this wall
i'm just going to run i think we need to
go away oh my god
and then we're okay
there's no way he could break through
that wall it could never happen you all
are so bloody i love the idea that on
the other side of that door there's a
very disappointing zombies like that yes
i gotta go home now oh man
he turns around you see that i almost
had him
i'm also working for bezos
j6 says tam is the master of cqc
yeah
so i started stabbing
yeah i stab as much as possible
especially because i have that health
regeneration i keep forgetting to do it
v you said yeah i put mine on mouse four
it's really good that's actually a
pretty good idea really good yeah
you're four mouse
yeah i have four nice
yeah yeah he's playing fps it's like tim
gettys out here
i'm so upset about that
i can't believe it
when we told well we told jared petty
the news it was hilarious the news when
we told you to play the good well
because like of course we had to lead
into
how does tim play games and it's always
it's funny because it's just a funny
weird thing
um
but in order to do that we had to tell
jared about how nick was playing games
at the start of quarantine
where nick would play warzone
on his ps5
with a mouse and keyboard
with
the mouse inverted
oh what why it just it seems like it
just kept going right they're not you
know
okay i have a box is this what i what we
want me to have oh we're going to like
delivering that somewhere okay i need to
get a miner
oh yeah so what you could do alana you
can come to the shop no no don't do that
oh nevermind did you already i did oh
these were free heels anyway it's all
good never mind i thought you were using
one of your things but when you're done
alana you can come to this orange box
and the refills up top you could just
pay a cheap amount to like refill ammo
and help but does it have half-life on
it no
no
let's go pull one i just refilled
everybody's ammo so that was probably a
waste of money
no i did it no we did you though no you
increased our capacity
i'm doing a quick item upgrade
god you're such a g dude thanks man i'll
do what i can
okay cool there's a defrib here i
accidentally bought something else
what did i buy
life comes at you fast all power oh dude
i'm about to buy a desert eagle [ __ ]
yeah i am you're gonna do it a little
later on dude yeah you know you you you
earned it thank you there's graffiti on
this wall that just says is the end is
nigh with a question mark on it
that definitely it would have been just
someone in writing the word vagina
nobody's writing poetry
at the end of the world writes the
i like to imagine that once that person
brought the end is nice someone behind
went yeah real original dude
oh hey there's a
hey get him andy
nice
nice okay so should i grab should i grab
one of these is this like an escort
situation yeah all right we're
delivering supplies to the diner oh it's
right over there that's not too far i
like this deagle chat oh i like this
deagle i could still melee with this
thing in my hand okay um
well but they don't call you the nitro
deagle oh that's too true that's true
you're gonna disobey your namesake like
that dude oh who dropped the box
what i i'm so holding mine
you can attack them with it uh you can
melee oh you can't oh it's a crap oh
this isn't the box y'all were carrying
it's a loot crate no no no no i need
that
wait what did i remember
or was it loot box what was that thing
that everyone had yes
they keep coming back and then shutting
down and then coming back
good for them for not giving up i guess
yeah they had like two good boxes and
then they just reaction like i like mass
effect box and i was like man i don't
want the other stuff though you know
like always oh good it just it gets real
samey real fast they had good quality
and dudes i did i did like their shirts
i still use my n7 hoodie
i put one of those
right what that's mad
rolling the horde dude every time i go
on it i'll just like hear some socks
but the socks are also pretty cool
they weren't bad oh big guy oh oh geez
oh behind us as well
oh god oh i'm unraveling
oh my god am i being attacked oh oh
hello
get off all right let's get to the door
immediately let's go yeah i see you up
there honestly
you inspired me tim you inspired me all
right we're trying to get through stupid
do we have a tool kit there's a door
over here that we can open
but this seems like it's ages away
we got to look through this building oh
here's a little hill
okay
sorry i'm just i'm just swinging the
knife wildly
it's great not a kid not a care in the
world yeah tam's a bad influence on us
man dude
[ __ ] rocks it rocks
it rocks
this smg
oh another toolkit
do we have both the boxes i don't have
my box anymore did somebody else grab
myself uh
i'm holding it okay yeah yeah i have the
other one oh look at this deagle
thanks gears all right nice eagle
little d
that's mine oh well
guy right there
he's a freaker
mother freaker
what's that dates going
loot over here
and then we basically just kind of like
have to set up
oh oh it's this mission oh we're at this
mission okay so this is in the box that
seems bad
why did that what
there's a bunch of loot here um also a
minigun god damn i delivered the box and
the ammo appeared everywhere
you'd like to see it dude
i'm about to place it wait oh weird
because when we played earlier today it
mounted on top of the car
oh yeah somewhere that's cool oh yeah
there is ammo up the ass holy [ __ ] you
aren't lying
oh you can mount these health kits yeah
i'm gonna put a hat
put it on top of the car over here put
it on top of this car because we had a
cool setup earlier
oh is this an auto turret
i didn't want to put it near the
exploding car just in case um
oh you can mount it too yeah look at
that that's cool yeah that's that
question should i repair the generator
um not yet we just there's a bunch of
like barbed wire laying around that
you're going to want to kind of oh yeah
yeah i see it i see it prep for this
area
do you guys think i should heal right
now yeah yeah i mean
okay this is a few
uh hidden buffer there as well and
there's also a lot of ammo and other
guns over here if you all aren't like
stoked what you got
damn it it's a little gap that should
stop them enough
i'm feeling pretty good about everything
i wasn't good i wasn't good no that's
just i'm good
oh two of us
and and uh remember that
boom
remember that there's a bunch of
grenades like right here yeah yeah
grenade here oh look there's another
okay how do you uh throw grenades
on mouse and keyboard um i set mine to
mouse five
i think it's three
three yeah yep cool all right
all right i think we're ready to rock
make it happen yeah let's do it
all right i'm gonna activate it
yeah do that you already know what
happens when you play with two people in
ai yeah i mean you could play solo as
well you just a lot of solo if you play
solos a lot of stuff you can't get like
achievements for example
though
that's nuts that you can't get
achievements in solo can't get
achievements and uh are you serious
there's no stat progression there's like
very little progress you get below dude
i don't think you get your supply points
either yeah you don't get any of that
[ __ ]
i don't know why absolutely why again
that's why it like really feels like
this game
should have micro transactions but it
doesn't it's very strange
it feels like it's built for it
i'm just damn it
very narrow field of view does that mean
you gotta have unlimited ammo
no 500 only okay save it for like the
big dudes yeah that's what i'm using it
for oh oh this is four minutes of of
different yes uh yeah oh okay it's gonna
get spicy yeah so to the left keep keep
an eye out with your uh with your pr
with your primary hand though
oh guy guy in here guy here he's down
nice
i'm just flicking over here i'm just
clicking heads and flicking dude you're
just flicking over there
you know dude nice maybe later after we
kill the zombies but yeah
live your life nothing better and you
can do both at once yeah are we doing
behind us right now nice
these zombies must not know that i gain
back to health when i stab them idiots
you're only hurting your future friends
i'm covered in blood yo this deal
[ __ ] rocks [ __ ] yeah you like it yeah
you could pick really though you gotta
have a look okay
on this mountain turret it's good fun
oh
oh you guys destroyed that guy ready
yeah i made fine lack of him
this yeah we struggled here real bad
today and the second time around we were
totally good because we were like just
super scared but we also ran out of like
i had no primary ammo at like the three
minute mark or something oh gee
oh yeah oh no we got right here
what uh what gun are you using elana
i don't know but i'm a big fan of
whatever it is okay does it look like a
smg
it's just really easy to get head shots
it's very very tidy
i'm kind of using it like a battle rifle
dude i'm just gonna shoot the plasma
pistol first
yeah
god how good is halo
honestly though
i'm just at the point where it's like
all right man we are cut we're a month
away from and two months away from halo
yeah i haven't finished um forza 4 yet
um horizon 4 so i keep thinking i should
do that and i feel like for the last
several years i'm just one year behind
on forza always for some reason i love
them though oh we're all covered in guts
tim you good home yeah i'm good he's not
a big guy exploding him uh okay
i think we should be fine yeah we're
good we're good
we're told
this turret placement was bad on my part
is it
how narrow the range of motion is oh my
god big dude big dude over here hello
that big dude right by andy
i didn't even know it was something that
you placed down i thought it was just
always on the car because that's where
nick was placing it i guess
was he still playing inverted mouse or
whatever the [ __ ] he was doing oh of
course
oh
okay
take this time to heal quickly oh my god
oh oh
holy [ __ ]
that was rad
okay on the right side by uh andy and
myself will overwhelm
oh you need to get overwhelmed yeah let
me be honest i feel like i have pretty
much the entire left
oh god
all right we are popping the [ __ ] off
this is crazy right now
oh i don't know my health
okay
yeah we got like 40 seconds left so i
guess he'll take that time to heal just
get
over here
yeah i'm healing i'm healing yep all
right there we go
oh my god i've missed every stab
you got to get tips from tam dude
he's got the [ __ ] on the lock yeah
you're going to line up your elbow
use your hips you know
twist
we don't have to kill everybody like the
clock just ends we're done
we're done skis
nice
they suddenly oh my ammo just ran out
what great timing oh we're beautiful
okay cool they're celebrating we're
still fighting there
yeah
earlier
you guys were [ __ ] useless on the
roof what were you all doing
we were down here
an hour that i've been playing this for
so far and i feel like it's pretty
simple
yeah like this is fun because i'm
playing with friends the card game does
feel complicated at first but i feel
like i already get it but overall it's
like it's pretty simple it's not really
doing anything that is different from
left 4 dead right like it's oh yeah you
didn't have to build those walls
remember those walls
that's true
it was a fortnite mini game for some
reason at some point yeah i was flossing
i don't know if you guys were flossing
but i was